[Musik]
Ampel in Notlage ohne Geld ohne
Vertrauen und damit einen guten Abend
liebe Zuschauer an diesem
Donnerstagabend das Urteil als karzruhe
hat alles verändert nur den Kanzler
nicht der hält an seinen Zielen fest und
verspricht den Bürgern dass sie von der
Finanznot nichts merken werden wie das
gehen soll bleibt sein Geheimnis für das
laufende Jahr könnte die Schuldenbremse
noch einmal ausgesetzt werden aber was
wird 2024 und danach die Opposition will
unter anderem das heizungsgesetz
rückabwickeln und in der Ampel will
bisher jeder etwas anderes wie befreien
sich die drei Parteien aus der
selbstgemachten Not sind Neuwahlen die
letzte Lösung auch darüber will ich
reden mit diesen
Gästen der Parteivorsitzende der CDU
Friedrich
März sask Esen die Parteivorsitzende der
SPD von Bündnis 90 die Grünen Katrin
Göring
Eckhart Robin Alexander
stellvertretender Chefredakteur der
Welt und der Ökonom Lars Feld sie sind
zu Gast bei Maybritt ner und die begrüßt
alle Gäste noch mal agesprochen herzlich
gestern stand die Regierung vor einem
Haushaltsloch heute ist sie einen
Schritt
weiter die Bürger und Bürger können
darauf vertrauen dass der Staat seine
Zusagen ih
keine Entschuldigung keine Ansage wie
die Ampel das Haushaltsloch stopfen will
der Kanzler tapt im Dunkeln Hohn und
Sport im
Bundestag sie sind ein klemner der macht
ihnen fehlt jede Vorstellung davon wie
dieses Land sich in den nächsten Jahren
weiterentwickeln soll sie können es
nicht die Ampel uneins überfast alles
außer Machterhalt Schuldenbremse
reformieren Schuldenbremse 2024 erneut
aussetzen wie es grüne und SPD
fordern ich bin noch nicht davon
überzeugt dass die Voraussetzungen für
ein notlagenbeschluss 2024 vorliegen
würden auch nach dem Koalitionsausschuss
gestern unklar wer wen von was
überzeugen konnte deswegen wird das
beste anstatt endlos dahinzus siechen
immer neue Beschlüsse zu treffen dass es
neuewahlen gibt je früher diese
Bundesregierung abgelöst wird umso
besser ist es für Deutschland der Termin
der Europawahl könnte ein solcher Termin
sein Friedrich märz ist bei uns Herr
März wenn Neuwahlen dann mit Ihnen als
Kanzlerkandidat das entscheidet die CDU
zum richtigen Zeitpunkt Herr Söder wä
sogar dafür Markus Söder sagt der friete
macht das Gut ja ist doch gut juni 24
das hängt jetzt sehr viel von der
Bundesregierung ab äh die
Bundesregierung muss Entscheidungen
treffen und dann werden wir sehen was in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen passiert
mhm Robin alexander ist bei uns
Journalistenkollege von die Welt
stellvertretender Chefredakteur da ist
dieses Haushaltsloch Robin Alexander so
groß dass darin eine Regierung
verschwinden könnte das haushalsloch wir
wussten ja bis gestern nicht wie groß es
ist und dann hat Christian nindner
Passon gesagt dass er jetzt erstmal 17
Milliarden sucht wie sich das errechnet
weiß auch niemand das kann man sagen W
überlegt der ET ist 470 Milliarden und
noch ein bisschen mehr die findet man
aber das Problem dahinter ist dass
hinter diesen Zahlen sich eine unsicher
verbirgt welche Politik soll eigentlich
gemacht werden also diese Fonds die
jetzt sozusagen aufgeflogen sind haben
überdeckt dass man sich nicht einig war
was man eigentlich tun will und das ist
natürlich etwas was sehr schwierig ist
in der Mitte eines Legislaturperiode zu
heilen wenn man auch schon vorh vorher
mit Geld zugedeckt hat und vorher hat
das ja auch schon nicht wirklich gut
funktioniert soon von daher die die 17
Milliarden finden wir deshalb fand ich
es auch falsch dass Herr MZ gesagt in
der Staatskrise Staatskrise ist in
Argentinien wenn die Geld g nicht mehr
gezahlt werden da sind wir nicht wir
sind in einer veritablen Regierungskrise
mhm Herr Merz ja hat er recht hat er
recht wir sind noch nicht in
argentinischen Verhältnissen und wenn
der Kanzler behauptet für den Bürger
wird sich wenig ändern in seinem Alltag
das wollte ich gerne noch mal nachfragen
irrt er da nicht wird sich nicht massiv
etwas ändern wenn man an die
preisbremsen denkt für die Energie wenn
man an die Gastro Mehrwertsteuererhöhung
denkt wenn man an die CO2 Bepreisung
denkt also kommt auf den Bürger nicht
tatsächlich mehr zu als der bekannte
Alltag das sind jetzt unterschiedliche
Dinge also diese diese
mehrwertsteuerhöung für Gastro war schon
vorher das ist einfach was ausgelaufen
egal wie man dazu steht mit den
energiepris aber trotzdem wird es teurer
und das ist zu zahlen ich wollte jetzt
nur sagen preiserhö egal wie man dazu
steht früher hat ja das Schnitzel auch
19% Mehrwertsteuer gehabt also das ist
ja jetzt kein Weltuntergang und die
energiepreisbremsen würden ein Problem
werden wenn die Energiepreise wieder
durch die Decke gehen danach sieht aber
im Moment nicht aus ich finde das
Schwierige an Scholz Argumentation
ist wenn es alles so undramatisch ist
warum macht die Regierung denn dann so
ein Drama und natürlich die Rente wird
weitergezahlt das barfk wird
weitergezahlt aber das gesamte Vorhaben
wie machen wir die Energiewende hängt ja
daran das wird jetzt neu verhandelt und
das ist keine kleine Frage sondern das
ist keine Kleinigkeit sondern eine
großigkeit bei uns ist s eskin die
Parteivorsitzende der SPD Frau eskin sie
freuen sich jetzt darüber dass es die
für 23 noch eine erklärte Notlage gibt
dagegen will die Opposition
offensichtlich nicht klagen ähm und
können damit rechnen dass dieser
Haushalt und dieses Geld für die
Regierung sichergestellt ist aber was
kommt danach glauben Sie tatsächlich
dass ab 2024 es noch mal gelingt eine
Notlage zu erklären erst recht mit dem
letzten Gedanken von Robin Alexander
dass es ja ganz viele Begründungen gab
warum die Lage eigentlich nicht so
schlimm ist in Deutschland auch seitens
des Kanzlers nein Frau Frau ner ich
freue mich natürlich nicht über eine
Notlage die wir erklären müssen für den
Haushalt ich freue mich vielleicht auf
Weihnachten aber
diese diese diese Krisen die sich ja
auch auf den Schultern der Menschen
stapeln in Deutschland die sind ja
vorhanden die sind ja nicht vorbei wir
haben aber in Ende 22 im guten Gewissen
und im guten Glauben daran dass es auch
richtig so ist
die Notlage erklärt um dann anschließend
für die kommenden Jahre Ermächtigungen
zu erlauben um die Krise weiterhin zu
bewältigen z.B eben die Gas und
strompreisbremsen zu finanzieren jetzt
hat sich herausgestellt durch das Urteil
des Verfassungsgerichtes dass das nicht
der richtige Weg war das ist in Ordnung
das akzeptieren wir selbstverständlich
und deswegen haben wir jetzt für
2023 sozusagen im Nachhinein diese Krise
noch mal erklärt 22 war es auch Ende des
Jahres das kann man schon machen mhm äh
wenn man eben feststellt dass die Krise
anders nicht zu bewältigen ist und wir
sind der Auffassung von der SPD dass
eben auch auch für
2024 weil die Krisen ja fortdauern und
auch ihre Folgen vor allem fortdauern
noch mal erklärt werden muss um noch mal
die Möglichkeit zu haben eben
Kredite aufzunehmen für die Bewältigung
der Krise Moment Moment aber worüber
jetzt auch gesprochen wird es ist ja die
Finanzierung der Transformation also der
der Klimaneutralität auch der Ansiedlung
von Chipfabriken also unsere unsere
Wirtschaft
zukunfähig aufzuhalten das ist ein ganz
anderes Argument es ist ein anderes
Thema
damit dürfen wir nicht argumentieren für
die Notlage das ist keine Notlage das
ist auch gut erklärt worden das hat
Deutschland jetzt glaube ich auch
verstanden der Bundes z.B hat erklärt in
seiner Regierungs der hat jetzt auch
verstanden dass man nicht mehr etwas was
wir seit den 60er Jahren des letzte
jahrhunderts wissen noch zu einer
aktuellen Notlage nutzen kann oder um es
zu begründen Herr März 2024
sie haben gesagt gegen 23 klagen sie
nicht weil sie diese notlagenbegründung
sehen und glauben dass die Regierung
natürlich dieses Geld zur Verfügung
haben soll 2024 würden sie dagegen
klagen wenn die Ampel eine Notlage auch
für dieses Jahr ausruft für 2023 haben
ja auch die Sachverständigen in einer
Anhörung des Haushaltsausschusses gesagt
das kann man so machen das kann man
reparieren ja deswegen werden wir das
uns genau anschauen es kommt ja am
Freitag also morgen in den Bundestag und
werden wir uns noch mal genau anschauen
da wird's ja noch anhörungnmer geben
aber ich gehe mal zunächst davon aus
dass man das so machen kann für 2024 bin
ich mit Christian nitner einer Meinung
der Staat hat kein
einnahmenproblem sondern er hat ein
Ausgabenproblem und ich finde dass dies
zunächst einmal in der Regierung geklärt
werden sollte und wenn das so ist und
ich teile diese Einschätzung bei 1000
Milliarden Euro Steuereinnahmen bei
445 Milliarden Euro Bundeshaushalt dann
kann es keine Notlage geben wenn man
jetzt mal 17 Milliarden Euro an anderer
Stelle einsparen muss ich glaube dass
das geht und ich bin ganz auf der Seite
von Christian l interessant wir fragen
Katrin Göring Eckert von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen glauben Sie dass diese Summe
stimmt Frau Göring Eckert reden wir nur
über 17 Milliarden oder wird das
eigentlich mehr sein weil die 15
Milliarden aus dem KTF noch dazu
gerechnet werden müssen na diese
Rechnung müssen wir uns tlich genau
anschauen ja genau und es geht ja um was
jährliches und deswegen reden wir über
dieses Jahr und die Notlage dieses Jahr
deswegen reden wir über nächstes Jahr wo
wir auch noch und das ist ja glaube ich
der entscheidende Punkt die Belastungen
haben werden leider aus dem
Angriffskrieg Putins gegen die Ukraine
und wenn man der Meinung ist dass man
weiter Waffen liefern will ich glaube da
sind wir uns einig wenn man der Meinung
ist dass man Wiederaufbau gewährleisten
will dann ist es eine außerordentliche
Situation unter anderem so aber wir
können nicht sagen bei allem was dann
weiterkommt und zurecht ist ja gesagt
worden dass die Frage wie kriegen wir
eine klimaneutrale Wirtschaft hin darum
geht's ja letztenendes dass man die auf
diese Weise in Zukunft finanzieren kann
und dann müss m wir über andere
Instrumente reden dann mssen wir drüber
reden wie die Schuldenbremse in Zukunft
ausgestaltet wird so und dann ist
dennoch ein klassischer Befund dass die
energiepreisbremsen ich komme noch mal
darauf zurück weil es die Leute ja
betrifft es hat ja Auswirkungen auf die
Bürger dass die von Christian Lindner
annotiert waren also er hat gesagt die
laufen aus zum Ende des Jahres und dann
waren plötzlich die Sozialdemokraten
ganz wütend of den Bundesfinanzminister
schauen Sie mal die strompreisbremsen
und
gaspreisbremsen werden ebenfalls zum
Jahresende
beendet einseitig das aus zuuverkünden
ohne dass wir das gemeinsam besprochen
haben das geht so nicht dass wir die
energiepreisbremsen gleich wohl zu
Beginn des kommenden Jahres beenden
können hat einen einfachen Grund und der
Grund ist dass die Energiepreise jetzt
nicht mehr so hoch sind das hat Herr
Scholz am Dienstag im Bundestag erklärt
warum hat Lars klingball den
Finanzminister also Herrn Lindner
beschimppft wenn Olaf scholzel sagt
Stimmen die sich untereinander nicht da
lagen ja paar Tage dazwischen da lagen
Tage dazwischen und Chris Lindner hat
eben diese Entscheidung ohne Absprache
verkündet dennoch ist sie richtig
gleichwohl hat chrti hat es gesagt und
war nicht mit Olf Scholz abgestimmt
glauben Sie das mit Ola Schulz war wohl
abgestimmt aber offensichtlich nicht mit
mit Lars kling weil wir wussten von
dieser Absprache nichts und deswegen
haben wir in dem Moment so reagiert aber
ist es ganz klar denn dennoch ist es ja
ganz klar dass die Energiepreis so sind
dass Sie den Deckel gar nicht mehr
erreichen den wir eingezogen haben um
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger übrigens auch
Unternehmen vor zu hohen Energiepreisen
zu schützen wir haben glaube ich mit
gutem Grund diese energiepreisbremsen
bis zum Ende des Winters begrenzt weil
der Winter eben unds wurde auch vor
einem Jahr ja noch gesagt dieser Winter
wenn ihr den gut übersteht ist gut aber
der nächste wird noch schwieriger in
Bezug auf die Gaslieferungen und die
Gasspeicher und die notwendige
Bevorratung und das hat sich nicht als
wirklich problematisch herausgestellt
wenn der Winter jetzt nicht sehr hart
wird was man was man noch nicht weiß und
deswegen und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass der Bundeskanzler auch gesagt hat
jetzt lassen wir die Strom und
gaspreisbremsen Auslaufen aber wann
immer es notwendig sein würde ja sind
wir selbstverständlich in der Lage zu
reagieren und das hat auch der
Finanzminister bestätigt so und dann
fragt man ja sonst sich ein logisches
Argument wenn diese Energie diese
Energiekrise als Begründung für eine
Notlage äh benutzt wird und auf der
anderen Seite aber eben diese
energiepreisbremsen auslaufen sollen ist
das in sich ein kleiner Widerspruch und
auf der anderen Seite haben die Menschen
natürlich den höheren Preis von vor dem
Krieg zu zahlen also weiß der
Bundeskanzler weiß der Bundeskanzler
Frau Göring Eckert das Gas doppelt so
teuer geworden ist im Vergleich zu 2020
und das Strom 15% teurer ist nee wir
sind ja jetzt wieder bei
bei Preisen die vor unter den Preisen
sind die vor dem aber nur mit
Neuverträgen das geht man ja
glücklicherweise machen kann deswegen da
würde ich auch sagen das regelt nun
wirklich der Markt und erstmal muss man
ja sagen es ist ein krasser Erfolg ne
also wir sind sehr sehr schnell
unabhängig geworden von Putins Gas wenn
ich mir überlege wie viele Jahre und
eigentlich fast Jahrzehnte immer gesagt
worden ist
von Angela Merkel und von vielen anderen
auch Sozialdemokraten da brauchen wir
unbedingt kommen wir gar nicht von Los
andere möchten gerne dass wir noch mal
über die Atomkraft reden aber im
Grundsatz haben wir jetzt eine
Stabilität der Energieversorgung ersten
und zweitens auch eine Stabilität der
Preise da kann man froh sein aber wenn
es aus irgendwelchen Gründen das kann ja
immer passieren in solchen krisenhaften
Zeiten schwierig wird dann werden wir
uns drüber beugen und werden sagen wie
unterstützen wir die Leute dass die
nicht in eine schwierige Lage kommen das
doch klar aber Frau elner hat ja ein
Punkt die Preise sind natürlich höher
und deswegen haben wir auch dafür
gesorgt dass in den Kosten der
Unterkunft für die bürgergeldbeziehenden
und dass auch im Wohngeld eine höhere
heizkostenpuschale drin ist die Kosten
sind jetzt höher das ist klar es war
aber von Anfang an klar dass Gas und Öl
teurer werden wür kan und dass wir
deswegen auch diejenigen die eben es
besonders schwer haben auch unterstützen
unterstü okay wir reden über zwei Dinge
jetzt folgend erstens über eine
Entschuldigung und zweitens über wie
kommt diese Ampel zu einem Plan wir
fragen Frau Göring Eckert ob auch sie in
der Rede von Olaf Scholz eine
Entschuldigung vermisst haben Katharina
dröge meine Fraktionsvorsitzende hat
gleich die hat es gemacht
Gemach das haben wir als Regierung
gemeinsam falsch eingeschätzt und das
bedauern wir das kann ich ganz klar
sagen das war für niemanden gut dass wir
das falsch eingeschätzt haben und
Christian Lindner hat gesagt das meine
Pressekonferenz von Montag auch gehört
da haben Sie was gesagt das ist ein
Fehler war das ist ein Fehler war Herr
Lindner sagt dass es peinlich war ich
finde es richtig dass einzugestehen wir
haben damals ich habe ja auch mit
gesessen bei den Koalitionsverhandlungen
wir sind damals davon ausgegangen dass
das geht und hatten viele Berater die
uns gesagt haben dass das geht und ich
sag das als jemand die jetzt nicht
finanzpolitikerin ist und ich bin auch
davon ausgegangen dass es funktioniert
aber man muss hinterher jetzt sagen nein
das war falsch und dann muss man nicht
nur diesen Fehler eingestehen sondern
man muss sich überlegen wie kommt man
aus dieser Situation jetzt wieder heraus
und da geht's jetzt auch nicht um
Parteipolitik und wer hatte Recht und
wer hatte nicht recht sondern ist jetzt
eine riesige Anstrengung und da sind
zwei Sachen wichtig erstens dass wir das
klimaneutrale die klimaneutrale Zukunft
der Wirtschaft hinbekommen damit die
noch bei uns investieren damit die bei
uns bleiben und zweitens ist ganz
zentral dass die Leute die wenig haben
diejenigen sind die am Schluss
draufzahlen und das ist der Punkt und
das könte man vielleicht auch anders
machen als man es bisher gemacht hat wir
kehren zurück zu der Frage Robin
alexander ist dran worin kann jetzt ein
Plan bestehen man hatte bei dieser
koalitionsausschusssitzung gestern nicht
das Gefühl dass in diesen anderthalb
stundeni sie wird gleich gefragt dass in
diesen anderthalb Stunden tatsächlich
schon offene Türen eingelaufen wurden
oder neue Verbünde geschlossen wurden
worin kann der Plan bestehen bei bei
drei Parteien die bisher eigentlich in
andere Richtungen gedacht haben na ja
vor allen haben wir ja gerade gelernt
dass Olaf Scholz noch nicht mal seine
eene Partei bescheid sagt der Spitze
also das ist ja irgendwie ich bin immer
noch ganz
erschrocken der Win der Plan besteht man
kann einfach gucken was man einspart ich
mE haben ja früher Regierung auch so
gemacht ist ja nicht die erste Regierung
der Welt die die irgendwie sparen will
oder sparen klingt ja auch immer so ich
fahre nur an die Nordsee statt nach
Ibiza und lege was auf die hohe Kante
damit meine Tochter studieren kann das
ist nicht gemeint sondern gemeint ist im
immer mehr ausgeben etwas weniger
ausgeben der der ET ist ja nicht kleiner
als er bei Merkel war der ist ja viel
viel größer als er bei Merkel war der
ist über ein Drittel größer als er 2019
war also ohne die Schattenhaushalte ne
also das ist ein sehr seltsamer Begriff
von sparen den wir verwenden und das
könnten die machen die Frage ist ob sie
es wollen und da geht ja genau der
Streit und im Moment hört man dass ein
Kuhhandel erwogen wird das also sowohl
die SPD und die Grünen ein
Lieblingsprojekt Schlachten müssen also
jeder gibt etwas und Christian Lindner
dann sagt okay dann machen wir 2015 noch
mal die Notlage wobi ich da sag 2024
Entschuldigung die Notlage W ich sagen
muss in so einem Kuhhandel dann wird's
dann schwierig weil eine Notlage kann
nicht die Notlage der FDP in der Ampel
sein das muss schon eine Notlage sein
die irgendwo auf der Welt passiert
ist ich würde empfehlen empfehlen da
tatsächlich mit denen zu sprechen die
auch dabei sind Kuhhandel werden in
dieser Koalition nicht geschlossen
sondern wir setzen uns zusammen schauen
uns die Lage an MA und machen uns und
machen uns auf die Suche nach Lösungen
das ist in in in
diesem ganz hervorragend in
diesem in dem Koalitionsvertrag sehr gut
gelungen und da sind ja auch schon drei
Parteien zusammengekommen die sehr
unterschiedlich sind die
unterschiedliche Herkünfte haben
unterschiedliche Erfahrungen haben auch
in Bezug aufs regierungshandel und die
sind zusammengekommen und sie sind auf
der Grundlage ja auch dieses Tricks
zusammengekommen den man für
verfassungsgemäß gehalten hat und der
ist nicht war wir reden übrigens über
zwei Dinge ja das eine ist die
Übertragung von Coron Hilfsmitteln in
den KTF in den Corona Hilfsmitteln die
wir sie waren nicht dabei aber wir
gemeinsam verantwortet haben war auch
schon eine ganze Menge Transformation
drin weil man die Wirtschaft auch in
Krisenzeiten stützt indem man sie sagen
wir mal schon auch in der Richtung
bewegt und nicht nur irgendwie stützt
und da waren digitale Wirtschaftsgüter
schneller ab schreiben und auch
klimaneutrale flottenumbau und so weiter
war eine Menge drin wurde aber nicht
abgerufen weil die Wirtschaft so da
niederlag und auch die Institutionen die
da ihre Flotten tauschen sollten dass
man kaum was genau kaum was abgeruf
wurde abgerufen wurde das wurde
übertragen das ist jetzt für falsch
befunden worden okay damit müssen wir
umgehen das andere ist aber der WSF das
war eben die
aufnahmeonisierentschuldigung ja genau
der doppelwums der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond der Ende
22 aufgenommen also Kredit tigungen wir
uns genommen haben um in den Folgejahren
die Krise die energiepreiskrise zu
bewältigen die
energiepreiskrise geht aus vom Überfall
Putins auf die Ukraine wobei man sagen
muss Anfang 22 hatten wir schon eine
Inflation von 6% und Probleme mit den
Energiepreisen aus Corona raus das muss
begründet werden D und das muss jetzt
das wurde damals begründet mit den
Energiepreis jetzt müssen wir eben jedes
Jahr begründen jedes Jahr erklären wir
haben eine Notlage jedes Jahr begründen
und das Verfassungsgericht sagt jedes
Jahr ist die Hürde für die Begründung
etwas höher und das werden wir und dazu
werden wir auch in der Lage
sein
zuinteragen die Transformation
Entschuldigung die Mittel für die
Transformation müssen wir tatsächlich
aus dem Haushalt Haushalt finanzieren
und das ist
jetzt ist die große Herausforderung
dafür die notwendigen Mittel mit
Sicherheit durch Einsparung bereit sind
dessen was man tun könnte oder man
erfindet ein Sondereigentum Klima sie
waren als Opposition bereit das bei der
Verteidigung zu tun könnten sie es sich
auch bei der Finanzierung dieser
riesigen Transformation vorstellen
ichmer zunächst auf die
Entstehungsgeschichte dieses Problems
noch mal zu sprechen kommen dass
hier ein verfassungsrechtliches Risiko
betrechtlichen Ausmaßes liegt das musste
der Koalition klar sein die
Sachverständigen haben das gesagt im
Bundesrat istes von Ministerpräsidenten
gesagt worden wir haben es
gesagt das war erstaunlich was noch
erstaunlicher war war dass die
Bundesregierung offensichtlich von der
Entscheidung am 15 November vollkommen
überrascht worden ist keine Vorbereitung
für den Fall dass das so ausgeht wir
hätten diese Klage ja nicht gemacht wenn
wir nicht der Meinung gewesen wäre dass
das so ausgehen könnte aber die
Bundesregierung hat das vollkommen
ignoriert und jetzt haben wir heute
Donnerstag der dritten Woche danach und
die Bundesregierung weiß immer noch
nicht wie sie damit umgehen soll und
Frau esin ihre Sitzung da gestern Abend
in allen Ehren aber wir wissen immer
noch nicht ob wir jetzt einen
Nachtragshaushalt das machen wir diese
Woche 2023 beschließen okay am Freitag
morgen aber ob wir 2023 noch einen
Bundeshaushalt 2024 beschließen wir
haben jetzt den 30 November mhm sagen
Sie dem Deutschen Bundestag immer noch
nicht also sie scheinen doch
offensichtlich in der Koalition sehr
viel größere Probleme zu haben als sie
es im Augenblick hier gerade darstellen
habr wir haben einen sehr klaren
Zeitplan
den der sehr ambitioniert ist und wir
hoffen sehr dass wir einhalten können
wenn wir wissen dass wir einhalten
können dann sagen wir
bes 151 das wird bis in der kommenden
Woche zu klären sein das ist ganz klar
son sie kriegen zwischendurch
interessante Angebote Herr März weil
unter anderem Frau dröge von den Grünen
sagt sie möchte sie gewinnen um die
Schuldenbremse zu reformieren und da ist
sie interessanterweise nicht allein weil
dass auch Kollegen Ministerpräsidenten
der CDU teilen
und oder sagen dass eben ein
weiterlaufen dieser notlagenklug wäre um
Zitat wichtige Investitionen zu
ermöglichen wir hören Ihnen mal
zu ich habe eine klare Haltung die
Reform der Schuldenbremse für
Zukunftsinvestitionen ist dringend
erforderlich und die Ministerpräsidenten
von Sachsen und NRW fordern einen
Sparkurs an dessen Ende kann dann ein
Pakt für Deutschland stehen und
vielleicht ein Gespräch über eine
Veränderung der
Schuldenbremse und wenn dann noch was
übrig bleibt und wir kriegen es mit den
Regeln der Schuldenbremse nicht hin dann
kann man sich das
angucken also wenn ihre Strategie war
die Ampel da ein bisschen zappeln zu
lassen haben das ihre Freunde vielleicht
erstmal nicht verstanden nein das ist
nicht die Strategie die Ampel zappeln zu
lassen ich meine wir haben ja gerade
hier heute Abend auch auch gehört dass
die Koalition offensichtlich nach
eigenen Bekunden dabei ist das Problem
zu lösen und wieso sollen wir heute
Abend oder überhaupt in diesen Tagen
über die Schuldenbremse sprechen wenn
die Koalition sagt wir lösen das Problem
und der Bundesfinanzminister sagt ich
komme mit dem Geld aus wir haben der
sagt's ja wir haben kein
einnahmenproblem wir haben ein
Ausgabenproblem so wenn wir kein
einnahmenproblem haben da brauchen wir
doch noch nicht mal über eine Notlage zu
sprechen geschweige denn über eine
Änderung der
Schuldenbremse Herr Günter auch anders
mit der Notlage ne hat in Nord hat in
Schleswig Holstein ein Problem unter
anderem durch die letzte Sturmflut wo er
wirklich in einem relativ kleinen
Landeshaushalt überfordert war und
deswegen nach der Landesverfassung eine
Notlage Erken mus eine völlig andere
Lage als die wür wir im Al nicht mit
einstehen dann hätten
auch mit Verlauf dieses Atal sind 1,6
Milliarden Euro das machen sie aus dem
Bundeshaushalt im Vorbeigehen das machen
dafür brauchen sie keine bundesweite
Notlage zu er wollen wir den Menschen da
er fragen Sie wie die den das
Krisenmanagement an der A finden ich war
da vor einem Jahr das sieht schrecklich
dort aus also mit der Begründung kommen
sie n wirklich nicht durch Robin
Alexander wird es gelingen aus diesem
verlang der
Ministerpräsidenten durch die Ampel
Kollegen herauszubrechen um für eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse zu kämpfen
also ich glaube Kai Wegner ist da ein
Spezialfall und ich habe auch gestaunt
dass er sich dieses Zitat getraut hat
weil das ist ja ein Landespolitiker aus
Berlin und die Berliner CDU woher Wegner
auch J schon Rolle spielte hat ein
Landeshaushalt hier mal angerichtet der
war so ungefähr zwischen Griechenland
und Simbabwe ich weiß und ein großes
Verdienst der deutschen Sozialdemokratie
den saniert zu haben übrigens also das
fand ich gerade so ist nicht mehr
Mitglied aber er hat den Haushalt
saniert wie auch immer spielt
aufal auf jeden Fall bei K Wener hat
mich überrascht und bei den anderen die
haben ja eigentlich nur gesagt erst soll
gerechnet werden dann soll Kons
priorisiert werden das ist so das
tahnwort für sparen und dann können wir
über alles reden und das wäre ja auch
komisch also das ist ja der logische
Dreischritt ja ja find ich finde ich
auch vollkommen richtig so heranzugehen
so muss auch eine Regierung herangehen
das ist jetzt nicht nur eine
Aufforderung der Ministerpräsidenten
zurecht weil die bräuchte man ja auch
wenn man die Schuldenbremse erweitern
will und darum geht's ja es geht ja um
eine Stabilisierung der Schuldenbremse
da bin ich dafür ich habe immer dafür
gestimmt auch bei dieser Schuldenbremse
nicht mehr aus der Opposition heraus
weil die wirklich schlecht gemacht war
aber ich fand es richtig als wir sie
eingeführt haben weil es eine
Generationenfrage so jetzt haben wir
aber noch ein paar mehr
generationenfragen und an denen können
wir nicht vorbei und die die
Investitionsstaus man muss es ja
wirklich in der Mehrzahl sagen sind
gigantisch und wir können daran nicht
vorbeischauen und deswegen sind auch die
landesministerpräsidenten so drauf dass
sie sagen also wir haben über 40
Milliarden Staus bei den Schulen wir
haben bei den straßenstaus was mit der
Bahn los ist wissen wir alle was in
unseren Städten los ist wissen wir alle
und deswegen jedes Mal wenn jemand sagt
wir können keine weiteren Schulden
aufnehmen dann hören die
bürgermeisterinen und die Bürger ganz
laut das heißt dann kein Geld für
Schulen kein Geld für Straßen kein Geld
für Schiene und auch kein Geld für die
Städte und das können wir uns nicht
leisten und diese aber ist das nicht
eigentlich entschuldigung wenn ich das
so Frage auch eine ganz geschickte
Strategie Robert Habig stellt sich jetzt
hin und sagt alle unsere Vorhaben müssen
kommen ja sind zentral und alle
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder sagen
unbedingt und hat damit natürlich sofort
die größten Fans auf der Seite wenn er
jetzt signalisiert diese Form zu fördern
und zu fordern und Industrieansiedlungen
zu unterstützen durch den Staat die
machen wir aus inhaltlichen Gründen aber
wir machen sie vielleicht auch aus
politischen Gründen weil sich die
Ministerpräsidenten dann einfach
bedanken gibt schon auch noch ein paar
wirtschaftswisensch wirschaftliche
Gründe es gibt soziale Gründe dafür und
man man kann man kann ja der Meinung
sein man möchte in dieser Situation dass
das was die Vereinigten Staaten machen
ne mit über 700 Milliarden Dollar dass
man denen das alles irgendwie hinschenkt
oder man kann eben sagen unser
Industriestandort ist eminent wichtig
und genau da drum geht's und dann kann
man priorisieren kann man sich streiten
was richtig was falsch ist an
zusätzlichen Mitteln oder sowas aber was
man nicht kann ist zu sagen man gibt es
auf man kann auch nicht Herr märz mit
Verlaub man kann auch nicht sagen
heizungsgesetz das schrettern wir jetzt
mal ich weiß dass sie sich darüber
geärgt haben ich sage nein weil das
nämlich für die LE die sich die teuren
Gaspreise der Zukunft und es wird ja
teurer werden CO2 Preis etc pp nicht
leisten können und wenn wir das jetzt
nicht machen dann werden sich noch mehr
Leute Gasheizung einbauen und die haben
dann hinterher total den Schaden und ich
finde das sozial nicht verantwortlich
wirtschaftlich sozial nicht Frau Göring
e in diesem Jahr sind die meisten Gas
und Ölheizungen eingebaut worden nachdem
sie das heizungsgesetz gemacht haben die
jemals in den letzten jah in Deutschland
eingebaut worden sind das zeigt doch auf
welchem welch sie das sind das ist
einfach falch wirschalich un
tig verhten hab
Wasil das Entscheidung ist für die
nächsten 30 Jahren die Preise werden
ste nur heute s die ist auch morgen und
übermorgen und wenn da Fehlentscheidung
getroffen werden dann dann
Kön wir können Gas und Öl nicht billig
halten das können wir nicht aber
Menschen hab Gas undöizungen eingbaut
wie nie in diesem Jahr mit ihrem
heizunggesetz dem
hegin das ist so das ist ke mit
heunggesetzärz sondern weil natürlich
die Kommunikation über das
heizungsgesetz so war nicht gut war das
war unser Problem nicht gut war dass die
Leute gedacht haben wir sichern uns da
jetzt mal ab ist kein
Kommunikationsproblem das Gesetz ist
falsch ne das Gesetz für ich nicht
falsch so wie es jetzt ist so wie es am
Anfang F ich falsch so wie es jetzt ist
find ich nicht falsch weil es einfach
ermöglicht auch Leuten die nicht viel
Geld haben und trotzdem Häuschen haben
weil es mögl ermöglicht Leuten die zur
Miete wohnen zukünftig mit günstigen
Heizkosten
zurecht jetzt ganz kurz noch mal eine
Frage zum heizungsgesetz weil da könnte
man formulieren Robin Alexander dass
eben tatsächlich grossum modo die
Menschen ja einen großen
subventionsbetrag bekommen sollen um
sich eine Wärmepumpe einbauen zu
lassen oder eine andere Heizung od
anderetim zu danken aber es ist 8 Monate
diskutiert worden ohne diese kommunale
wärmeplanung die wird jetzt
vorgeschaltet die muss finanziert werden
ist das etwas wo jeder Bürger der jetzt
eine kaputte Heizung erstmal sagt ich
weiß nicht so richtig ob ich eine
einbauen soll also ich glaube jeder
guckt doch ob bei ihm eine Wärmepumpe
passt ja so und wenn die super passt
dann sagt er doch nicht ich nhme keine
Wärmepumpe s der entscheidet das halt so
und aber wenn man jetzt das gesamtding
anguckt also eine Regierung macht
Gesetze und Förderung damit die Leute
Wärmepumpen einbauen die Leute kriegen
so viel Angst und bauen Gas und Öl ein
also dass das nicht gut gelaufen ist
wenn sie das nicht
zugestehen und wenn wir auch mal
weitergehen das finde ich auch an wen
sielauben an der Debatte so immer ja wir
müssen das Geld jetzt machen für den
Klimaschutz wie sieht's denn gerade aus
mit Klimaschutz die heizungskiste ist
völlig nach hinten losgegangen sie haben
heute ein Urteil bekommen von dem
Gericht dass sie klim Ziele nicht
einhalten haben n be Klima das gleiche
gemachtwaltungsgericht entschuldig muss
man erklären Oberverwaltungsgericht
heute
berlinbrandenburg die gesagt haben dass
beim Verkehr und bei den Gebäuden
früer in der merkela wurde ja gesetzlich
festgelegt jeder Sektor muss seine Ziele
erfüllen und Rechenschaft ablegen wenn
er nicht kann muss er nachbessern und
als die Ampel gemerkt hat dass sie beim
Verkehr das nicht hinkriegen haben sie
das Gesetz geändert das ist schon heikel
geht aber noch aber dann haben sie
gesagt weil wir das Gesetz ändern müssen
uns bis es in Kraft ist auch nicht dran
halten und das fand das Gericht
überraschenderweise falsch man schon
miterzählen dass die Merkel Regierung
keine Maßnahmen ergriffen hat weil nicht
weil nicht Schar weil es noch nicht
scharf geschaltet war ja das ist jetzt
die erste Instanz das Klimaschutzgesetz
die Novelle ist ja noch nicht wirksam
deswegen sind
sie da wird auch Revision eingelegt
werden aber am Ende müssen wir ja alle
tatsächlich beitragen dazu dass dieser
Klimaschutz
auch milarden ausgeben viel CO2 sparen
vielleicht gar nicht stimmt so und also
es ist auf jeden Fall notwendig D D die
Gebäude dass in wir in den Gebäuden mehr
als 30% der CO2 Emissionen verursachen
und dass wir deswegen daan müssen so
vielkehr auch und hab gesagt als
Ergebnis wenn ich das einmal kurz sagen
darf an dieser Stelle macht ganz schnell
Tempolimit dann kommen wir weiter und da
sitzt jetzt die die Instanz nicht hier
die das auf gar keinen Fall will aber es
ist wäre eine Maßnahme ganz schnell ohne
Geld
Abau diesen Vorschlag werden wir auch
noch mal diskutieren müssen wie viele in
der Koalition vielleicht durchbekommen
der FDP gegenüber wir können es ja ruhig
aussprechen Verfassungsrang wollte ich
noch mal sagen her März wie diese
schultenbremse hat auch das Klima
Verfassung Verfassungsrang und man
könnte auch die Opposition könnte
natürlich sagen noch mal wir lassen uns
eben etwas ähnlich Wichtiges für das
Klima einfallen wir denken vielleicht
über einen klimasoli nach wie es
damals den einheitssoli gegeben haben
weil es ein Jahrhundertprojekt ist und
wir denken also ich wollte nach ihrer
produktiven Rolle Fragen ja ich also die
Rolle ist sehr produktiv und sehr
konstruktiv aber ich will ihn mal an den
beiden Beispielen sagen was wir für
Erfahrungen mit solchen Instrumenten
machen Sondervermögen Bundeswehr haben
wir gemeinsam eingeführt die Verabredung
war nur für langjährige Investitionen in
die Bundeswehr über die Sommerpause mal
eben ohne uns zu beteiligen beschlossen
laufender Betrieb wird auch finanziert
aus dem Sondervermögen ah sie sind
enttäuscht über den was heißt enttäuscht
das ist einfach ein Bruch der
Verabredung die wir mit der Koalition
gehabt haben Soli deutscheer Einheit
Ende 2019 ausgelaufen alles bezahlt so
der Solidaritätszuschlag musste aber auf
Wunsch der SPD beibehalten werden für
die oberen Einkommen wird heute noch
erhoben glauben sie dass wir vor diesem
Hintergrund ernsthaft mit dieser
Koalition über Verabredungen sprechen
die sie danach auch einhalten mü so mal
abgesehen davon wir sind anassen mich
mal ausen ich hab eben auch lange zehört
hat die CDU
angeführt haben sie haben sich geweigert
den Soli ganz abzuschaffen und der hätte
seit Ende 2019 komplett abgeschaff aber
sie hatten doch die Kanzlerin und sie
haben den Finanzminister also Frau es
jetzt verkaufen sie Leute hier nicht für
dumm sie haben das gewollt sie haben es
in der Koalition blockiert und haben es
nicht mitgemacht und es ist bis heute in
Kraft und sie haben in dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr angefangen zu
Asen für die Betriebsausgaben der der
Bundeswehr obwohl wir verabredet hatten
nur für langfristige
Investitionsvorhaben so und das ist
genau der Stil dieser Regierung in der
täglichen Arbeit und jetzt bevor wir
überhaupt zu solchen Instrumenten kommen
stellen wir doch mal die Frage kommen
wir eigentlich mit dem Geld aus das wir
heute haben was im Bundeshaushalt
verfügbar ist jetzt gebe ich ihn mal
zwei weitere ganz konkrete Beispiele in
Brüssel liegen fast 30 Milliarden Euro
für den next generation Fond der EU die
von Deutschland bis heute nicht
abgerufen worden sind wir liegen bei
irgendwo 10% Quote italien liegt bei 70%
sie kriegen es nicht auf die Reihe die
Bedingungen zu erfüllen um das Geld aus
Brüssel nach Deutschland zu holen
zweites Beispiel die bah völlig klar die
Bahn muss natürlich wirklich renoviert
werden da ist ein unternehmenschenker in
der Bahn das gehört der Bahn und damit
dem Staat mit dem Verkauf dieses
Unternehmens könnten sie für Jahre das
Schienennetz der Bahn ausbauen aber
diese Koalition will das Unternehmen
nicht verkaufen weil sie der Meinung
sind dass sie die besseren Unternehmer
mit einem der größten Logistikkonzerne
der Welt sind Potenzial ohne Ende bevor
wir an das Geld unserer Kinder gehen
denn darum geht es es geht um die Frage
ob wir die Kinder und Enkelkinder mit
noch höheren Schulden belasten und an
der Stelle sagen wir ganz einfach nein
jedenfalls solange wie wir so viele
andere Möglichkeiten haben das zu
wichtigen Punkt herrz jetzt haben wir
ger gerade gesprochen der Berliner
Haushalt sei konsolidiert worden durch
Verkauf von landeseigenen Wohnungen
beispielsweise und dadurch ist ber
dadurch ist schauen Sie sich doch mal an
was dabei rausommen ist was hat der Mark
geliefert in Berlin sind die Mietpreisen
in die durch die dicke gegangen und wir
haben ein riesenmangel an
Wohnungen sind in Berlin keine Wohnung
da den Haushalt konsolidiertin weil die
Wohnungen verkauft worden sind aberor
weil die Stadt keine möglich die Menge
der Wohnung bleibt doch gleich egal ob
der Staat sie besitzt oder die privaten
es müsste einfach mehr gebaut werden es
müsste mehr gebaut werden und und und
die Stadt der Staat also sagen wir mal
die Stadt Wien hat nicht so ein Problem
die hat ihre die hat ihre Wohnungen nie
verkauft okay aber es ist ja dennoch so
dass ist der Ampel nicht gelingt das
Wohnungsbauprogramm dass sie aufgelegt
hat ich habe jetzt gerade von der
Haushaltskonsolidierung gprochen weil
immer wieder immer wieder ja Länder
Kommunen auch der Bund versucht haben
sich zu konsolidieren in indem sie mal
eben irgendwas abstoßen das ist doch nur
ist doch nur ein stru das ist auch nur
ein Strohfeuer also das ist doch keine
keine Verantwortung V der
Haushaltspolitik okay die
Verkehrsminister davor müssen wir noch
sagen waren and die scheuer und Herr
dobrin die haben das glaube ich auch
nicht so richtig toll hinbekommen mit
der Bahn ich erwähne es nur noch mal
kurz und jetzt wird endlich Lars felz
begrüßt an dieser Stelle Uni Freiburg
heute in Luzern und wir grüßen dahin
sehr herzlich an diesem Abend Herr Feld
sie sind das darf ich sagen auch noch
Berater von Christian Lindner und einer
der ich will nicht sagen letzten aber
einer der ganz klar entschiedenen
hundertprozentigen Fans der
Schuldenbremse die so bleiben soll wie
sie ist und sie lassen sich daavon auch
nicht
abbringen guten Abend Frau ilna und
guten Abend an die Runde und an die
zuschauerinen Zuschauer zu Hause ich
lass mich davon nicht abbringen die
Schuldenbremse erlaubt sehr viel
Flexibilität das haben wir im
Konjunkturverlauf gesehen ins Besondere
in der coronakrise sie erlaubt auch
viele Investitionen das ist nicht
wirklich das Problem
wir haben eine gewisse
Begriffsverwirrung in der
Diskussion nicht unbedingt heute Abend
aber in der öffentlichen
DEB
unterscheiden ich denke die muss man
unterscheiden denn Subventionen sind ja
nichts anderes als Transfers an
Unternehmen mehr ist das ja nicht das
heißt es wird vor allen Dingen auch an
alte Industrien gezahlt damit die in der
neuen Welt der Klimaneutralität
überleben
können es geht immer auch um ein
Arbeitsplatz ent von dem wir nicht genau
wissen was es noch zählt vor dem
Hintergrund der Demografie wenn überall
Arbeitsplätze fehlen und deswegen bin
ich nicht davon überzeugt dass die
Subventionen die hier gezahlt werden
sollen der richtige weg sind sind
Milliarden für Ansiedlung eben von
Fabriken das haben sie gerade gesagt
keine Investitionen weil sie denken
diese Unternehmen würden das unter
welchen Bedingungen auch sonst tun sie
kommen ja eben nicht nach Brandenburg
ohne 10 Milliarden oder denken Sie die
tun
es
sie müssen nicht unbedingt den
Mitnahmeeffekt betrachten dass die also
die Subvention mitnehmen und trotzdem
kommen würden das reicht ja aus zu
fragen warum investieren die denn nicht
von sich aus in Deutschland und wir
haben eine Reihe von Unternehmen in
anderen Branchen die sehr wohl von sich
aus investieren ohne dass Sie irgendeine
Subvention des Staates kriegen also ist
das Problem eigentlich eher dass ich das
nicht rechnet für diese Unternehmen und
deswegen der der Staat irgendwas dazu
schießen soll das ist aber nicht
wirklich eine produktivit steigernde
Maßnahme die uns zu Wachstum führt man
muss noch mal erklären dass die
Intention vieler Wissenschaftler auch
vieler Politiker vor allen Dingen eben
auch der Ampel dahin geht zu sagen dass
Investitionen ausgenommen werden müssten
von der Schuldenbremse eben weil sie
einen doppelten Nutzen haben
und die Transformation hin zu
Klimaneutralität erst möglich
machen sie sehen keine keinen Verlust
gerade auch der energieintensiven
Industrie für die jetzt Robert habex seh
kämpft um sie hier im Lande zu halten
und anderes mehr das würden sie nicht
stützen und nicht versuchen
zu
bezahlen ich würde das nicht stützen ich
denke schon dass wir auch in der
energieintensiven Wirtschaft eine Reihe
von Unternehmen haben die aufgrund
weiterer Spezialisierung im Land bleiben
werden und andere Investitionen tätigen
die Chemie hat das ja über die
vergangenen Jahrzehnte auch bewiesen
dass sie das ganz gut kann aber wenn wir
über Investitionen reden auch für den
Klimaschutz und für den Übergang zur
Klimaneutralität dann reden wir über den
Ausbau der Stromnetze wir reden über den
Ausbau des Schienennetzes
wir haben auch noch andere Themen bei
der Digitalisierung das zahlt ebenfalls
auf den Klimaschutz ein wenn wir Smart
Grids produzieren können und einrichten
können darum geht es und das ist im
Rahmen der
Schuldenbremse ohne Probleme machbarhm
und nun verweist eben jener Robert
habbeck häufig auf das Umfeld in dem
sich deutsche Unternehmen da bewegen und
verweist darauf dass es viele Länder
auch genauso machen von China bis USA
hören wir mal rein das sagt sich so
leicht dann mit weniger Subvention die
halbe Welt subventioniert genau diesen
Prozess China und Südkorea und die USA
vor allem also wir sind ja in einem
hochkompetitiven Umfeld ein
hochwettbewerblich im Umfeld deswegen
ist das erstmal alles nur
Gerede noch mal die Frage es war eine
Replik auf Christian Lindner muss man
sagen der ja auch sich gegen
Subventionen ausg gesprochen hatte
und Robert habck kämpfte da im
Deutschlandfunk genau für das Gegenteil
sie sagen das spielt keine Rolle und wir
können auch auf diese Arbeitsplätze
verzichten in eben einem großen
transitionsvorgang ja wir haben ja
zugleich den Übergang
zu einer anderen demografischen
Situation händeringend werden überall
Arbeitskräfte gesucht und für eine
Ansiedlung von Intel mit 3000 neuen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern müssen
Personen gewonnen werden die dann
woanders nicht zur Verfügung stehen und
da muss man klar sagen auf diese Art und
Weise verzerrt die Subvention auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt die Situation doch sehr
deutlich ich will noch ein Wort wenn Sie
das erlauben dazu sagen wir wir müssen
da mitmachen in diesem
Subventionswettlauf davon halte ich
nicht viel insbesondere im Hinblick auf
die USA ist doch festzustellen dass die
USA schon von vorne rein bessere
Investitionsbedingungen bieten die haben
eine niigere Steuerbelastung sie haben
nitigere arbeitsk kosten sie haben
niedrigere Energiekosten und weniger
Regulierung und jetzt kommen eben die
Subventionen oben drauf in Form von tax
credits von Steuergutschriften
und D machen die USA das was die wir
Europäer ja vorsteuerabz noch was
anderes also Steuergutschriften die
gezahlt werden ähm und und auf die Art
und Weise folgen die USA doch bloß dem
was wir Europäer schon lange machen wie
lange finanzieren wir denn schon
Subventionen
erneu dann geht's hier ganz kurz da
wirst doch eigentlich eher angezeigt ja
ich wollte nur sagen dann geht's hier
wirst du eigentlich eher
angezeigt pardon sprechen sie zu Ende
fragen sie ja ne ich wollte die Frage an
die Politik geben ob es unwichtig ist
eben oder ob es in der energieintensiven
Industrie Herr März jetzt unwichtig ist
äh um diese Arbeitsplätze zu kämpfen
wenn die neuen Arbeitsplätze noch nicht
da sind die alten gehen und die neuen
sind noch nicht da das ist die Situation
lass Held hat ja in seiner Analyse recht
ich teile die Einschätzung grundsätzlich
muss allerdings sagen das jetzt als
Gerede abzutun weil wir hier vielleicht
konkret Entscheidungen treffen müssen
die einmal auch im Einzelfall beachtet
werden müssen finde ich einfach
unangemessen ich bin in der Sache
trotzdem der Meinung dass es richtig ist
diese beiden Chipfabriken in Magdeburg
und in Dresden anzusiedeln wir brauchen
hier eine
strategische Unabhängigkeit Europas in
einer ganz wesentlichen Industrie über
die wir zurzeit nicht verfügen und das
müssen wir eben leider unter den
gegebenen Umständen die so sind wie Herr
Feld das gerade beschrieben hat machen
damit wir hier diese Prozesse in Europa
auch besser eigenständig und souveräner
äh
führen können Unabhängigkeit von China
Unabhängigkeit auch von Taiwan taiwan
ist mit TSMC ja der größte
Chiphersteller der Welt des deswegen
setze ich mich sehr dafür ein dass wir
das hinbekommen das geht auch aus dem
laufenden Haushalt zu finanzieren für
diese Chipfabrik in Magdeburg sind zwei
Drittel bereits im Haushalt budgetiert
da fehlen jetzt noch 2,8 Milliarden
dafür braucht man nicht die
Schuldenbremse zu lösen also wir können
das machen aus dem laufenden Budget und
so wie Herr felt das gerade gesagt hat
die Schuldenbremse gibt ja sehr viel
Flexibilität ich will mal nur die Zahlen
sagen damit wir wissen worüber wir hier
reden mit der Schuldenbremse können wir
im nächsten Jahr 22 Milliarden Euro
zusätzliche Schulden machen mhm mit der
Schuldenbremse ja nicht so als ob uns
das hier jetzt hier so oder gar wie hab
exagt mit den Händen auf dem
Rücken fähig macht hier zu investieren
also von daher das geht und das ist
trotzdem kein Widerspruch zu dem was her
Feld von den grundsätzlichen
Rahmenbedingungen gesagt hat die in
Europa auch in Deutschland natürlich
nicht besser sind oder aber interessant
dass sie sagen die haben eine solche
importanz auch für Deutschland und für
die neuen bundesl ich bin nun wirklich
überzeugter Marktwirtschaftler aber
manchmal muss man eben auch mal aus der
Situation heraus Entscheidungen treffen
und solange wir Arbeitskosten
Bürokratiekosten Energiekosten und
Steuern nicht wirklich so haben wie z.B
die Amerikaner oder andere Länder auf
der Welt und wir trotzdem diese
Industrien brauchen müssen wir natürlich
auch sahen da müssen wir auch für Geld
auf den Tisch Gegenwort von Herrn Feld
oder die Frage geht Klimapolitik ohne
Subventionen also was ist ihr
Gegenvorschlag also zum einen ist mir
bewusst dass man auch in pragmatischen
Situationen das machen muss was mir als
ordnungspolitischen Schweinkram
beigebracht worden ist also Subventionen
zu zahlen aber die Führungsrolle in der
Klimapolitik muss die CO2 Bepreisung
haben und die Anstrengung internationale
Vereinbarungen mit einem Mindestpreis
für CO2 zu haben das ist der
entscheidende Punkt und mit dem Ausmaß
an Subventionierung mit dem wir im
Moment durch Deutschland ziehen wird
dieses eigentliche leitinstrument die
CO2 Bepreisung in den Hintergrund
gedrückt davon halte ich relativ wenig
ich muss auch noch mal wenn sie mir das
erlauben dazu sagen m im Grunde ist es
doch wichtiger wenn man schon den USA
folgen möchte die allgemeinen
Bedingungen zu verbessern also
beispielsweise bei der
regulierungsintensität nachzusteuern
hier übermäßige Regulierungen zu
reduzieren oder bei der Steuerbelastung
nachzusteuern auch da gibt es
Möglichkeiten also diese Möglichkeiten
bestehen sie bestehen auch im Rahmen der
Schuldenbremse und da sollte man meines
Erachtens eher ansetzen so und da waren
wir auch dran mit der Stromsteuer
Beispiel weise die ja gekürzt worden ist
und anderen Dingen und dennoch
ich willz ausdrücklich recht geben das
sind strategische Entscheidungen die da
getroffen werden für diese
Halbleiterindustrie die wir hier in
Deutschland in Europa haben müssen um
auch unabhängig zu sein das gilt aber
natürlich genauso für die chemische
Industrie auch für die Pharmaindustrie
übrigens dass wir in künftig selbst
wieder und unabhängig von China
Antibiotika herstellen können nicht auf
die Vorprodukte von dort angewiesen zu
sein das haben wrend Corona gemerkt dass
sehr problematisch sein kann so und die
Stahlindustrie ist natürlich für unsere
Automobilbranche für die Maschinenbauer
für viele anderen die Stahl brauchen und
die jetzt grünen Stahl auch verlangen
dringend notwendig strategisch notwendig
und deswegen brauchen wir auch da eine
unabhängigkeiten ich kann natürlich auch
her Feldt dem Stahlwerker der der heute
an seinem am am Hochofen oder im an
seinem Arbeitsplatz arbeitet eben nicht
sagen sucht dir doch einen Beruf in
dieser neuen Industrie oder in dieser
neuen äh Wirtschaftsform die sich durch
die Digitalisierung ergibt da findet
sich doch sicher was das so einfach geht
Transformation nicht und deswegen glaube
ich müssen wir nicht einfach drüber
reden dass der Markt und der weltweite
Markt ist schon richten wird sondern wir
müssen in Europa und in Deutschland auch
strategisch vorgehen also ich ich stimme
zu was diese strategische Entscheidung
angeht ich glaube nur das wird nicht
reichen wenn wir über den weiteren
Investitionsstau reden und wir können
diese Ansiedlung machen und ich bin auch
dafür und das in magleburg hat ja auch
damit zu tun dass D übrigens die
Rahmenbedingungen sehr gut waren dass da
nämlich die erneuerbaren Energien schon
da waren das war ja einer der
Begründungen hat ja Herr Haselhoff auch
sehr deutlich gemacht aber wenn wir über
40 Milliarden Euro Stau bei den Schulen
haben dann ist das eine zentrale Frage
für die Zukunft und wir können nicht
sagen wir können den Kindern die
Schulden überlassen aber die Schulen
sind einem dramatischen Zustand das ist
eine deswegen sind die
Ministerpräsidenten dabei das gilt für
die Straßen ganz genauso das gilt für
dieses Thema öffentliche Gebäude ein
ganz zentraler Punkt wenn wir sparen
wollen was die wärmewende angeht und was
ne was was die Zukunft angeht auch auch
da klimapolitisch sehr relevant und
deswegen das sagen darf dafür müssen wir
die Schuldenbremse öffnen um sie zu
stabilisieren das ist glaube ich der
entscheidende Punkt Kön nicht aus dem
laufenden Haushalt machen und da muss
man auch sagen Herr märz das werden sie
zugestehen das ist jetzt auch nicht das
Problem der Ampel dass diese
investitionsstausen sie waren da nicht
in der Politik in der Zeit als die so
krass aufgelaufen sind aber trotzdem
kann man nicht sagen dass ist jetzt in
letzten zwei Jahren Bildung glaube ich
ist unstreitig ein zentrales Ziel wir
reden die letzten 10 Minuten die uns
bleiben darum wie man sparen kann also
wo sind denn diese unnützen Subventionen
es gibt Dinge die müssen subventioniert
werden durch den Staat und es gibt
unnütze Subventionen das sieht man von
Partei zu Partei verschieden es gibt ein
kleiner Bruch wir bedanken uns bei Lars
Feld für alle seine Erläuterungen in
Sachen Schuldenbremse und stellen jetzt
wahrscheinlich die Frage die sie viel
mehr interessiert nämlich worauf wir uns
hier am besten verständigen sollten was
würden Sie am Esten streichen Herr Feld
nur das noch wir hören mit ihnen ja
quasi Christian
Lindner ich glaube so einfach ist das
leider nicht dass Sie Christian Lindner
hören aber die Idee die
Herr Alexander eben genannt hat dass
jede Partei
aus ihrem Lieblingsbereich äh Projekte
die sie für verzichtbar hält in den Topf
gibt das ist genau das Richtige und von
Seiten der FDP geht es dann nicht darum
zu sagen wir geben nichts sondern es
gibt genügend Steuervergünstigungen bei
denen auch die FDP etwas tun kann auch
was tun kann und oh oh oh oh alles klar
können sie konkreter werden dann lassen
wir Luzern doch noch ein bisschen in der
Leitung bin ich
gespannt woran denken sie da ich werde
an der Stelle nicht konkreter es gibt
aber eine ganze Menge davon
stiftus W sie haben noch eine Chance sie
werden berühmt heute
abend
arbeitslos okay also genau darüber
verhandeln jetzt natürlich die
Koalitionäre der Ampel und angeblich
wollen und sollen es die drei Herren
unter sich ausmachen und diesem einen
Herren in Luzern danken wir jetzt noch
mal ausgesprochen herzlich Danke einen
haben sie gesagt dem einen in Luzern
danken wir sehr herzlich Danke fürs
dabei sein wo spart man was sind unnütze
so in aler es gibt jetzt gerade dieses
schöne getckel zwischen mütterrente und
Rente mit
63 wäre super wenn es das getckel gebe
aber es gibt's glaube ich gar
nicht grün frage ich gleich Frau Göring
Ecker s letzten Donnerstag bei uns in
der Sendung und schlug beides vor grün
finan muss man
sagen beidem sind nicht die Grünen
Schuld das muss man festhalten nämlich
die sogenannte mütterrente damit hat
sich Angela Merkel 201 ein tollen
Wahlsieg gekauft und mit der Rente mit
63 hat sich Andrea nahes Frieden in der
SPD gekauft und sind beides schöne Ziele
aber die sind ungefähr mit 7 Milliarden
pro von den beiden gerade im Haushalt so
nur die Idee dass die SPD davon noch mal
runterkommt und selbst Herr März würde
sich ja nicht trauen wir machen noch mal
was bei der mütterrente zu sagen hier
also das ist wie kamen wir in diese Lage
also ich mein 10 Jahre läuft es super
immer mehr Geld Schubel hat Rücklagen
gebildet immer mehr Geld alles da das
ganze Kapital aus Europa strömt nach
Deutschland und am Ende dieser Zeit
sagen oh die Bahn ist kaputt die Schulen
sind
kaputt eventell
finzchft
der ganz kurz kritisiert ja gerade genau
ich sag sofort dass die CSU schuld ist
an müterren habe ich doch schon
freiig nur wir haben ein Problem dass
wir zu viel konsumtive Ausgaben haben
und das ist auch wor Energiewende
brauchen wir extra Geld Chips Chemie hat
Frau eskin gesagt die Schulen die
Straßen die Bahn was wollen wir noch aus
dem Bundeshaushalt bezahlen das sind
doch alles staatliche kernausgaben und
wir haben tatsächlich das Problem dass
die Ausgaben die festgeschrieben sind so
groß sind dass man nichts anderes mehr
machen kann oder jedes Mal weniger und
ein Problem das ich potenziert wenn man
für die Schulden die man aufnimmt ganz
viel Zinsen zahlen muss und so sind auch
andere Länder in Europa an die Wand
gekommen kommen die Finanzmärkte haben
die irgendwann gegen die Wand gestellt
das ist ganz ganz gefährlich auch für
eine Demokratie und deshalb finde ich a
auch arg wenn man bedenkt wie weit die
Grünen mal vor 10 Jahren in dieser
Finanzpolitik waren Daniel bas ist da so
ein spätausläufer von dass sie im
bundestagag Verschuldung Verschuldung da
waren sie doch mal viel weiter also sie
haben doch mal angefangen mit
Nachhaltigkeit und nächste so ja hab ich
auch vor gesagt zurecht ja so und was
machen wir mit diesem Vorschlag
Entschuldigung ganz kurz das also können
sie er kommt ja von Daniel bas Frau
Eckert ist es vorstellbar zu sagen m
mütterrente versus Rente mit 63 beides
kostet wahnsinnig viel Geld und beides
können wir uns nicht leisten klingt
glaube ich für ein Finanzpolitiker sehr
einfach ich würde sagen das für
unsichert Leute sehr sehr stark wir
werden bei dieser Frage
Renteneintrittsalter reden wir immer
über Flexibilität und nicht über den
einen Tag an dem es dann zu Ende ist
finde ich vollkommen richtig aber es
gibt ja genügend andere Sachen über die
wir reden können ja jetzt also nehmen
wir immer noch dass 3 Milliarden Euro
ausgegeben werden jedes verdammte Jahr
dafür dass dienstweggen Besteuerung
privilegiert wird nehmen wir die
Mehrwertsteuer Dienstwagen got nehmen
wir die Mehrwertsteuer nehmen wir die
Mehrwertsteuer für Fernreisen ja das
sind auch 4 Milliarden Euro
Mehrwertsteuer für fernreis die
Mehrwertsteuer für fernreis ja es ist
interessant ne ich gebe jetzt mal zu
wenn sie es auch nicht wissen kann ich
auch zugeben WUs ich auch nicht dass
dass wir dafür so viel Geld ausgeben
oder eben nicht einnehmen und
und die andere Frage wird auch
kerosinbesteuerung sein das ist auch ein
Thema über das man selbstverständlich
reden muss es ist kein Ladenhüter
sondern wir machen es immer noch nicht
und das ist das Problem es macht kein
Land auf der Welt wir sind
her Entschuldigung Frau esin dann ist
her März dran Frau eskin Rente mit 63
versus mutterrente die Rente mit 63 mü
ja alle was geben die Rente mit 63 ist
ja schon längst keine Rente mit 63 mehr
mittlerweile ist es 64 sehr bald ist es
65 das ist eine vorgezogene Rente um z
Jahre für Menschen die sehr sehr lange
gearbeitet haben
alsoel jetzt will ich mal gerne sprechen
dann kann gerne auch Andrea nales das
ist eine vorgezogene Rente für Menschen
die sehr sehr lange und meistens hart
gearbeitet haben und die eben sagt die
unsäigen Frühverrentungen nehmen zu das
ist was anderes das ist was ganz anderes
Entschuldigung hat wirklich nichts
miteinander zu tun wenn Menschen die 45
Jahre eingezahlt haben dann in Rente
gehen weil sie ansonsten nämlich
vorzeitlich in Rente gehen müssten und
Abschläge hinnehmen die die die die die
Rente das Rentenalter hochzusetzen ist
für die W wäre für diese Leute schlicht
und ergreifende Rentenkürzung weil die
können einfach nicht mehr
deswegen W 45
jahrearit
beispielsweise bin mit allem Herzen
dabei ich will niemandem was wegnehmen
wollen und möchte die Entscheidung nicht
fällen und möchte in ihrer Situation
auch nicht sein ich möchte aber Wissen
wo dächten Sie dass man sparen kann wo
sind Subventionen aus der Sicht der
Parteivorsitzenden Saskia esken die
unnütz sind die weg müssen weil etwas
gespart werden muss das ist ganz
bestimmt ein Thema dass wir nicht heute
Abend und hier im konkreten besprechen
das ist kein Wunder dass er Feldt dazu
nichts sagt weil die ressours alle den
auf weil die R Entschuldigung weil alle
ja das mag sein aber sie hat auch was
anf sie hat auch was angeführt was
sowieso nicht kommt das konnte sie
leichterdings tun die Ressource haben
jetzt alle den auftragen Blick in ihre
Haushalte zu werfen und zu überlegen ob
es da nicht Dinge geäbe und da bekommen
wir ein Ergebnis und dann werden wir uns
da drüber beugen das machen wir nicht
Herz ist ein großer gehört nicht hier
gehört nicht hierher sie können ja noch
mal überlegen vielleicht fält
einitionsausschuss wird nicht hier
durchgeführt ja aber es kann ja was
geben was sie richtig ärgert wo sie sagt
was ist denn das für ein Quatsch also
ich glaube wir sollen mal bisschen aus
dem K klein jetzt mal raus Bürgergeld wo
kann der Staat sparen Herr märz ist es
tatsächlich so dass und damit haben sie
und ihre Kollegen natürlich viel auch
Nachrichten gemacht in der letzten Zeit
sie glauben dass man bei den Ukrainern
aus dem Bürgergeld in ein normales
Asylbewerber leistungsgesetz W man sich
der Kommunen bedanken gehen soll lass
wir ih erstmal sagen gesagt wir sprechen
ja über das Bürgergeld und seine
Wirkungen wir haben ungefähr 10% des
Bundeshaushaltes jetzt Bürgergeld also
Transferleistungen praktisch in die
Arbeitslosigkeit so die Frage ist ja
warum haben wir 2,6 Millionen
Arbeitslose und 700.000 stellen die wir
nicht besetzt bekommen warum sind in
Deutschland nur 20% der Ukrainer in
Beschäftigung und in Holland 70 und in
Polen 90 so das kann man erklären das
hat nicht nur etwas mit Geld zu tun aber
lassen Sie mich vielleicht noch mal
etwas an zu dieser Transformation wir
sprechen ja hier im Grunde genommen über
die Frage wie finanzieren wir eigentlich
die klimaneutralit unser Volkswirtschaft
und da haben wir eben mit der Koalition
vollkommen unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen die Koalition will das
durch sehr hohe Subvention machen und
das war ein Hinweis von her Feld den wir
vielleicht noch mal aufnehmen sollten
wir hatten mal in Deutschland einen
Konsens das a über CO2 Bepreisung und
über ein klimageld geht na das kommt
eben nicht das ausgesetzt komm klimageld
kommt nicht und die CO2 beeisung ist
ausgesetzt Word wir haben ja das
Durcheinander im Augenblick in der
Koalition dass sie eigentlich nicht
wissen wie sie eine unglaublich hohe
Summe an Subventionen für die privaten
Haushalte Stichwort heizungsgesetz und
eine sehr hohe Summe an die Unternehmen
Stichwort Transformation sie haben eben
gesagt grüner Stahl alles prima nur die
Methode die sie da anwenden die führt
eben dazu dass sie extrem hohe
Transferleistungen aus den öffentlichen
Kassen leisten müssen es gibt eine
bessere Methode so und an der Stelle
haben wir eben nicht nur ein disensz im
im kleinen hinterm hinterm Komma was
können wir da
Milliarden ich ich mE fr hab mit KT
meine frich haben wir mit den Kontakt
und die glauben dass über den CO2 Preis
das ist die Transformation stimmen
können schauen Sie einer der von Ihnen
am häufigsten zitierten Wissenschaftler
ist her Professor Edenhofer und der hat
am letzten Wochenende im Vorgriff auf
die Klimakonferenz in Dubai jetzt noch
mal sehr klar gesagt wie das auf der
Welt zur Zeit läuft und hat das sehr gut
begründet und das ist n kein
Parteigänger der CDU sondern ein
derö unseres Landes der genau an dieser
Stelle gesagt hat der Mantel wird falsch
eingeknöpft von ihnen ich sag's mal mit
meinen Worten sie machen es falsch und
das löst einen extrem hohen
subventionsbedarf aus und den Kriegen
sie nicht finanziert und des V so eine
Schuldenbremse lösen und an der Stelle
sagen wir einfach nein das geht so nicht
okay der Frau elner ist aufgefallen dass
sie ein bisschen einen anderen fad
genommen hatten ich wollte sie ger ich
über das wirklich wichtige Thema okay
ich wollte gerne trotzdem fragen ein
paar weniger Ausländer ein paar weniger
Ukrainer ein paar mehr weniger
Arbeitslose und dann ist unser kassenpr
g ne das ist natürlich nicht der Fall
nur ich sag mal wenn wir 100.000
Arbeitslose mehr im Arbeitsmarkt hätten
wären das 3 Milliarden für die
öffentlichen Kassen ja die wir einsparen
so das heißt also wir hätten einen
enormen Hebel wenn wir einfach die
Beschäftigungsquote in Deutschland
erhöhen würden wir wir müssen
qualifizieren da wird Geld gekürzt wir
müssen Sprachkurse machen da wird Geld
gekürzt wir haben zur Zeit ein massives
Problem im Wohnungsmarkt natürlich wegen
der hohen Nachfrage auch durch den Zuzug
durch die einwandung so aber das sind
alles komplexe Probleme wenn wir jetzt
mal etwas auseinander halten was was
läuft da falsch im Arbeitsmarkt glaube
ich dass wir eine Menge anders machen
könnten wenn wir mal die Frage stellen
was läuft in der ganzen
klimatransformation falsch ist das ein
völlig anderes Thema da glaube ich
können wir auch gze Meng and warum sie
dem Bürgergeld zugestimmt haben wir
haben ein wir haben nicht zugestimmt
sondern wir haben ein
vermittlungsausschussverfahren gehabt
Frau das wissen Sie ganz genau und da
haben wir einen Kompromiss mit ihnen
machen müssen weil wir wenigstens das
Prinzip fördern und fordern vom
Grundsatz her in das Gesetz reinalten
wollten die Anhebung die Anhebung des
Bürgergeldes die sie jetzt machen haben
sie nicht von uns machen siein haben wir
nicht
zugestimmt Kompromiss zugestimmt den wir
im Vermittlungsausschuss mit ihnen
gemacht haben damit wenigstens das
Grundprinzip Fördern und Fordern im
bürgergeldgesetzten das ganze Gesetz ist
von der Grundauslegung falsch in der
ersten Abstimmung vor dem
Vermittlungsausschuss haben sie den
Regel Beit nur der Anhebung des
Regelsatzes in der Sozialhilfe
zugestimmt und das war eine
teil da gibt es
Gesetze jetzt es gibt
verfassungsgerichtsurteile das hält der
März auch ein und wir haben eine schöne
letzte Frage an Robin Alexander wo
würden sie eigentlich sparen was ist die
unnötigste Subvention in Deutschland es
gibt ganz viele ne weil das ist gar
nicht so dass diese ganzen Transfers nur
an arme Leute gehen die gehen in die
Mittelschicht also wir hatten im im
letzt in diesem Jahr hatten wir eine
eine Subvention für Leute die schon eine
Immobilia haben schon ein KP haben schon
ein Elektroauto haben und eine
Ladestation dass die sich auf den
Carport noch die Solarzelle setzen
können diese hat nur 300 Millionen
gekostet kann man sagen es ist zu klein
für unsere Runde war in einer nach
ausgebucht so und das sind alle die das
gebucht haben ich finde ich gönne den
das alles super aber musste das vom
Steuerzahler bezahlt werden oder jetzt
Bereinigungssitzung der Plan das
Elterngeld also das Geld das junge
Eltern kriegen das ist nämlich je mehr
man vorher verdient hat do höher ist das
also es ist
umgekehrt das hat schon sein Grund
umgekehrt das hatte schon
Grund
abern die Idee war dass nicht mehr
Leuten zu zahlen die
300000 € versteuertes Einkommen zu
verscheinkommen im Jahr haben ist ja
jetzt wirklich nicht wenig sondern das
auf 150 000 rterzusen und in der
bereinung das schaffen wir nicht das ist
uns zu hart also wir zahlen jeder der
arbeiten geht zahlt das Eltern Geld für
Leute die 200 000 € im Jahr selber
versteuern und da muss man doch sagen
und ist jetzt nicht redlich was sie hier
machen das Elterngeld wird für
diejenigen bezahlt die eben eine gewisse
Zeit Mütter oder Väter nicht arbeiten
und dann eben dieses Gehalt nicht mehr
bekommen und das war ja genau die
Absicht auch Akademiker Familien die gut
verdienen ist zu ermöglichen mal eine
Zeit lang sich für die Kinder auch ihre
Partei es eingetütet hat mit Frau
vonlein aber der Effekt dass ein Staat
der überle
en
fr fest angestellt ist wir reden über
Leute im richtig hohen Bereich müssen
wir die zusätzlich in dieser Höhe
subventionieren und diese Frage kann man
stellen und die stellen wir
unterschiedlichwen schon und auch dafür
sind wir dankbar sowieso ein großes
Dankeschön für die Sendung
he sehen uns wenn Sie mögen am kommenden
Donnerstag wieder 22:15 Uhr gleiche
Stelle gleiche Welle und noch mal ein
großes merci für die Runde kommen Sie
gut durch den Abend
Co